Which program in the right is for liver detox?
There is only one liver support and it's only 15 minutes. Is that enough to detox the liver?
Remember go back to you have access to the seven phases of detox. Don't think that
And your liver isn't detoxing. So
What are some programs that can help support liver detox? There is a
In you have a true right the person who asked this question. There is a
detox
Program in your foot bath your eye on pro-way and there's a detox program in the
In the frequency folder as well
Can't think of the name of what it does
It is called detox. So look at that. That could help with liver detox
And again is the right going to be
Your main tool to detox the liver. No, it's not. So
That's not that's not your main tool to detox the liver. Your main tool to detox your liver. It's going to be
Well, number one try to decrease your your toxic load
Your toxicity input and then you're you're working on your
Phase six phase five phase four then three two one
Um, and that's going to be mainly through chemistry being through nutrition